let's talk about whether this is or
isn't an existential crisis for FIFA I I
think it is you know it's already been a
series of bad news stories for them over
the last few months and and this is just
taking it to a whole new level now you
say a new level for people like yourself
for people like us but as we establish
just a few minutes ago in another good
conversation on FIFA the member
countries that put slept Sepp Blatter in
power who have elected him repeatedly to
the position of FIFA president don't
feel the same way about it bribery and
corruption are you know the way business
gets done in parts of Africa and parts
of Latin America parts of the Middle
East and parts of Asia well i think you
know football's a global sport and i
think it's got to come together as one
and I you know I think whatever rules
certain countries or certain people have
they're going to realize that a lot of
other countries have other rules so
somewhere along the line something's got
to give but Eric in defense of those
countries or who participated for all
these years and haven't pushed back was
it necessarily their job to they weren't
the government they weren't the
regulator's they were simply there
there's the chart of the game they're
the constituents no I mean they're there
they they are the members who represent
those countries and who consequently
represent the player but they were
participating in a game they were
participating in a framework that they
couldn't necessarily control remember
Sepp Blatter has been running this
organization for over 20 years I would
submit that their participants in an
enterprise possibly even a scheme and
that leads me back to you Nigel it's
like he who pays the piper calls the
tune right so if money has been what's
driving corruption as is always the case
if somebody shuts off the money tab and
the sponsors like Visa and coke and
adidas you want to be the guide and FIFA
is that what ultimately Eric you want to
be the guy to shut off the money tap to
be the one guy to do the good thing
sorry Nigel oh well you look there's no
doubt the sponsors have huge pan out
about forty percent of FIFA's revenue so
they've got collectively an awful lot
power and I think they've got to act
collectively to sort this out if you
know if just individual brands start
breaking ranks and start saying things
that's one thing but if they all pull
together they could have a real impact
and really damaged FIFA very badly and I
think then you'll start to see some
changes and see them taking some notice
if you look Nigel among FIFA's top
sponsors and we'll remind everybody who
they are there include Hyundai for
example okay and coca-cola and Adidas
and here we have Gazprom even the
Russian oil and gas company which of
those five let's just take those five as
an example would be likeliest to break
ranks first most concerned about its
image most concerned about this
reputation worldwide such that
abandoning Sepp Blatter is the right
thing to do well I think coca-cola's
already already made comments in the
past and I think that you know brands
are so paranoid about their image these
days they're so concerned about doing
the right thing and being corporately
socially responsible this is just the
sort of thing that an awful lot of them
will not want to be involved in so
you're going to start to see brands
really kicking back and making a lot
more noise and and and creating a lot
more fuss than they ever would have in
the past clearly those brands are
concerned about their image I'm guessing
Sepp Blatter is very concerned about his
does it surprise you that he was nowhere
to be seen at the press conference today
the moment where if he is innocent he
should have been sitting at the podium
saying the buck stops here well he he's
the ultimate politician and he's managed
things from his own point of view
superbly well how he gets out of this
one I don't know it's just such a mess
and you know to think that this great
sport is is in this sort of dire straits
at the moment is is unthinkable but
something's got to happen and yes you're
quite right the man at the top should be
coming forward and telling people what
he's going to do to sort it out is it
safe to say for the moment Nigel that
any company unaffiliated with FIFA won't
go anywhere near that organization until
there's some resolution to these
allegations you you would have thought
so but it's a you know it's it's a crazy
sport
ball in it and the World Cup is the you
know probably the biggest global
marketing event even more so than the
Olympics because the amount of branding
that's available it gets to so many
countries it gets two huge audiences
though they won't be short of other
sponsors looking to get involved so you
know certain individual sponsors will be
a little bit worried about saying oh
let's just ditch it let's forget about
it because they this huge rivalries that
there's mastercard visa there's added as
Nike there's Coke Pepsi all these brands
are paranoid about letting the
opposition in to this event that
delivers so much having said that you
know it is a damaged sport at the moment